hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to a gmod horror map
with Yomi - hello everyone
God mine was so energetic yours was just
so subdued and cause I was thinking
about the ship of Maki ma she just
mentioned before the video yes I did let
me cut to that right now
I mean it's really cool because this is
like a piece of history here history of
marki mash way back before we were
banging each other you know say that
word no oh what a weird fantasy it never
actually happened it didn't oh man I saw
all these pictures and he's like [ __ ]
about these photos bring this up again I
thought we were bum bum buddies but oh
well each other now but either way what
I was saying is that this is death of
the dream for the same guy who made this
made all the other death of the dreams
some of the greatest maps are we played
the first one was not that great if you
remember but then it got progressively
better so this one should be the best of
all four it sure shouldn't it but please
not say that out loud because it's going
on my channel okay one of the twenty
million rules do not please remember
this oh good so I jump down off with you
yes kill vice but not in real life cuz I
would be so heartbroken if you died I
died with you because I can't live
without you yes please no wait is that
mean you're gonna kill me is this some
weird suicide pact please don't die I
think knocks out corpses got dragged by
a serial killer and we're locked in the
Attic now knocked out corpses as in we
were dead with corpses but we were also
unconscious and they woke us up by
bringing us back from the dead and we're
pretty much you don't need some explode
my brain with you all okay oh yeah I
know everyone knows that I'm the most
intelligent gamer around but either way
look at those numbers over on that board
show you and put them into the pipe dial
Wow let us me yeah which one did you try
three five seven
no no try one eight two nine one eight
two nine beep no that one 9 - 0 9 - 0 no
try 104 I think the last one right I
know what if it doesn't work
aha how was the word for me four four
zero seven eight that must be the one
berry drop the party balloons read about
note on the flume ah okay
welcome to hell you will not survive Oh
straight to the point
hey Amin is here why do we get Oh God I
can't get the page out of my face there
we go good alright since I'm recording I
will go first
I did not see anything there was a thing
walk by Oh sigh polite and I was closing
the door behind us
oh I see are you gonna lock me in a room
again so that they can be possessed
later you and a desk and a bed whatever
be that way I'm gonna go alone if you do
not read rule number seven on page 24 it
said do you not kill each other
well what about making each other dance
dance hey ami you're not dancing okay
alright alright then dance didn't even
hurt you I'm not even scared of you
you're invincible Wow kill each other
okay fine then there's stuff in all
these drawers they actually work hey
wait a minute was this on the wall
before you are not alone yeah are you
ready to you a second ago I didn't
listen to a word you said I apologize
you never listen to me
I would love to listen to you you're my
favorite Britt that's it whoa I'm
getting a whole bunch of text messages
all at once Amazon is blowing up my
phone right now
there was a jump-scare hope you had fun
wherever you were I was looking in the
room at the ice okay go in that one what
eyes yeah over here where Oh should I go
into this one yes you shelling I'll wait
out here
not nothing whole lot of nothing you get
the next one
why do I get the next one because I said
so and I make up the rules and we've
been away for so long that you know I
think I should be the boss in this
relationship for one oh geez alright you
wear the pants then what thank you I
think you have an anger problem do you
use and really think I enjoy this
probably what he was talking to us no no
did you make this no yamimash maybe I'm
the one maybe I'm the one who posted all
this I couldn't tell if that was a
menacing laugh or just constipated or
something yeah I don't want to know Oh
time is ticking what happened don't you
remember this map has a lot of ways for
us to cry hi thank you god damn it you
sons of [ __ ] these aren't even good
jump-scares they're just like loud
noises I see you must be for a doll cuz
that's what keys are for you are right
yamimash wow you are so smart
thank you one DW lessons must have done
you good I learned from the best
thank you was that mother oh the best is
not me okay I'm sorry
Hey look held back and a TV phone I'm
busy I'm gonna look at the TV when what
happened in TV well there was something
on that a second ago but icebergs you
looked at it I didn't look at it Oh Soph
looking at my phone it broke I saw your
face Oh
am i that ugly do not look at me look at
me
latter-day where'd you go yummy I didn't
see where you went trust no one they
will betray you why will they betray me
ah okay what do I keep getting
everything Sun's up the ventilation shot
was gonna but it hurt it hurt a lot yeah
it feels good yummy step in it okay yeah
it's good I don't know why you haven't
been picking up the health packs yummy
oh that's how fast yes indeed there are
if you haven't been looking right right
there on the oh yeah you haven't played
this game I took the health pack sorry
oh there's another one right here here
let me hang I do okay I shoved it up
your yeah you're welcome
Walsh I've done my buzz I was about to
say yes that's what I did say I shoved
it up your butt ah that's a big object
some rooms should not be entered alone
okay I'll hold your hand not no I'm
gonna go on this room alone I feel good
about it alright okay bye what is this
III came in anyway some but some are
best sure what oh [ __ ] we locked it what
what happened I'm stuck Yomi open the
door well I'm moving Oh God Oh yummy
you're gonna die this but yeah you're
probably gonna die I wish it weren't
this way wish this was not happening son
of a [ __ ] I posted all of this you
didn't you goddamn it I'm stuck in one
of the other doors
yeah stole series this is just like the
Soul series is it like the saw series
there's a trap where the guy gets in
this box and then the walls closing and
crush the other guy yeah I remember
one now's the major spoilers I'm
Hoffmann and you're the other no no no
no no no spoilers you're the guy and I'm
that guy you all okay that's much better
wasn't Hoffman I gotta get back to you I
gotta everyone's hate me now cuz I said
that no of course yeah face again oh
come on why you gotta be so mean about
my face you know I was born this way I
try to surgically make it look bad am i
crushing you by the walls and don't you
think I'm beautiful
okay I'll go but only because I love you
look at the [ __ ] yeah mm-hmm
you want to put a flavor bag over my
head again Yami oh this looks like a
friendly robos very nice buns anything I
don't think you're oppressing them right
Oh curiosity kills people think I am
insane I want to release you from your
sins
I'm just curious MA but did you write
these notes no but I got a shotgun
you're doing me first I do this for you
son of a [ __ ] you stupid ass zombie
piece of crap stole my body ah
you know I lost my gun because of you I
had a pistol before don't you remember
oh yeah you did
oh no I'll be carrying oh no this is
gonna be one of the rooms with Billy in
it I don't know how long I've been here
I hear other people that's I had to kill
my friend to like a bright yeah he wants
us to suffer to fight for our lives he
keeps asking me to participate I won't
commit those great reading yummy you
really captured the essence of who that
guy was I wanted you to feel like I was
him in his last moments
uh-huh you want me to get this one yeah
I won't participate in his games I'm
happy here so very happy happy happy
happy happy happy happy happy happy
happy happy happy happy you told me to
read it
obviously this store doesn't even sound
like I wanted to capture who I was in
his locker fine
I mean why would I it wasn't my fault I
didn't when I was hungry they understood
that better he sounds like a mad
scientist thank you I know I was
capturing who he was
you did a really good job there isn't
another room oh all right I'll do this
wow what happened thank you for a table
phone burnin how you will die what do
you think that's pretty succinct what
did you do to this lady oh I mean well
yeah that's a nice voice but what the
hell did you do to this lady why is this
lady dead you don't want to know why
have I what have I told you about Cassie
say people well she has my blood so I
don't know how I killed it I a cyanide
type on the ground
ah yeah I I ate the can of beans again
mark you know or out of beans we don't
have no more beans
he's gonna shoot me I will not because I
need to save it for the zombies that are
gonna come in this room I found a key no
I picked up a key okay I thought in the
nursery all right yeah it didn't it
didn't unlock it so I guess we got a
backtrack all over here no well it's
gotta be a secret button let me boo-boo
bit again ball bat ba ba boo boo boo boo
nothing's happening boobity boo model
bleep Boop
how thing the vending machine buttons on
it don't mean don't you sass but Oh
Boober Boober
oh do be bee do food label Diddy will ah
ha ha I knew it beautiful nobody boo me
first
I don't this looks dangerous in here the
floor could form no apparently not okay
the end is near apparently No Oh dead
body
Oh gain that room March which room this
one this room okay
although it looks safe you can trust me
it seems safe there's dead guys in there
mm you are not alone mark I know you're
here with me like always in my heart
am i though Oh No yes can you see me
mark yes I can't where'd you go I saw
your crowbar I'm taking a long time to
drown me it's gonna be a while the
singing just like my heart okay I'm dead
now I have been open so I can get your
dead corpse and do things with it
why would you do things with it it's all
bloated and gross yeah honey probably
Ryan yeah morning well I have to wait
for you to go
oh great fast thank you I know I'm so
fast I don't even know what happened I
just got pushed into it like I did yeah
that's so mean I'm heartbroken although
just to be honest you have been
betraying me a lot of this entire
episode I'm starting to suspect our
friendship
be all it was cracked up to be no you
know what I've had a change of huh you
can trust me oh now I can trust you all
of a sudden you're all better by the way
found another gun I don't want to shoot
you because I love you I know I know
well the first time I wanted you to die
this time yeah yeah I failed it killing
you so you know what you broke my heart
by doing that so I have to kill you just
then hey look it's the armory there's
something move map did you wear it ran
down here it's no longer Cristo okay as
if you knew it was coming yeah but I
smell something else here mmm smells
like monsters okay well monsters would
smell like dead flesh you would think
both of my hair is a mess no I'm very
happy sounds like ice cream does it
you smell ice cream yeah weird do they
have ice cream trucks in Britain land
you don't think we have ice cream trucks
I'm serious wondering when I get
universal thing everyone has that no I
know things are totally different where
you live yeah there's something missing
from this control panel we gotta find it
[Music]
no no
yeah the sing break is over I don't know
where else to go we need to find a
secret thing to add on to the thing
maybe it was back here somewhere you go
look somewhere else because we need to
find something to bring and put it in
our ional okay
no okay hey did I hit you no I saw it
happen from a distance to look like you
exploded well I'm ochem I didn't take
any damage Oh we'll find there Jesus
it's a party on the wall that says they
hunger by the way wait a minute you know
okay good I'll feed them later you know
when you find that war did you check
anywhere panics for my life and I didn't
see anything at all okay sorry sorry
did you open all of these yes I did I
opened pretty much sobbing thing yeah
thing
oh there's not a thing what are you
talking about oh is this a health pack
that's a health pack you do [ __ ] damn it
yeah you're a doofus box is no up
nothing behind the boxes sorry I read it
okay I'm going back a bit well we didn't
go through okay what we didn't go
through here the room of blood yamimash
oh my god we can paint in the blood we
can you are not my only Oh you could
have saved me there's a freakin water
flood level or you know far away that
one didn't even try you could've made
you go oh it's always a cool dude
yamimash sure glad to be trapped in a
nightmare with you your wife I was
trapped in that you just let me die soon
I probably would have but then I
wouldn't have been happy about it so
cago in the nursery yeah but we can't go
down here because the water pump let the
water level go down and is there
anything down there mark me check gosh
hey I found something a shotgun
let me just close these things and turn
the water pan back on once then you
can't do that you couldn't do it if you
tried well you just stay down there
front of a second but some nothing down
here is that what there it is all right
you just stay there I'm not doing
anything there's nothing down let me put
it back up yeah trying to murder me
again and you can't because you're
impotent on murder nests you're murdered
to pretend forgot the bun yummy yeah
there is no button here what there is no
button you trying to scare me there's no
burden you did Joker
and then and this jayveer others
where are the other drugs going I look
like a cop do hmm you're not Batman you
don't know that I'm not a superhero then
I'll take off that mask no get your head
back in the game no it's not a mask
Barney Who I am I'm the shadow in the
night I'm what the criminals fear most
Mac yes I'm Batman
can you can you shoot things and fly
across buildings and stuff Matt no Hey
maybe I don't remember his name his name
might be Jeffrey Jeffrey Jeffrey it's
just do you want to taste the fists of
justice no I don't want you to punch me
do you want to taste the peepee of
justice oh no okay just pressing I mean
uh uh hey I ran into bad man back there
was really weird sounded awfully like
you
no of course not why would it Batman's
totally way sound cooler than me
Batman's way cooler than you
sorry not that cooler maybe a little bit
wait turn around turn around close your
eyes look at that wall over there
they're so interesting right that dead
body in the corner
whoa
I could have sworn never duels that
before but you know what you know he was
hitting those wooden panels I think we
triggered some pretty surprised what you
do do not turn around and show everyone
the doors in the walls oh yeah sorry I'm
not good at lying it - okay sorry sir
but I think the toilets are that way
kill me sir let me just get you on
your way well why do you find that
weapon I'm just using my muscle arms
here called in that door it's floating
what oh I thought I had them right there
right there sir see right there hey man
you get in front of him Oh God
why why should you let's get these bands
everything got burnt off mm-hmm
I swear to God if you abandon me hmm
seems like a good statement no no got
some good points on it confess me I will
kill you wait yummy
I found another gun Oh confess your sins
Yami bad time I stole a penny sweets
from a stole bad dog bad are you very
much that's good I like that I like what
I hear yeah no don't don't be a change
yeah that's good gonna come and give you
justice give you justice all over your
face I'm gonna just everywhere you want
taste my salty justice did you find your
putz
you don't want my justice in my pants do
much justice can't fit in Hey
oh yeah that looks that looks fun oh no
no face your fears yummy so I try and
grab the box on the thing you want me to
face my fears fingers see baby oh baby
something happens
didn't hear anything electricity in
spots just grab the bottom I grab the
ball yeah I got it well there's nothing
new it how do we grab the oh you turn it
off oh it's a switch oh oh
I'm if I turn it on you can't oh I can
taste your fears
great I'm a beast you are you are the
Beast you're the ball I ain't scared of
yummy
there was something in this room and it
changed escape your most of scared okay
alright alright don't like me in no more
rooms again I bet that one's gonna
change too oh my god
told you Jesus man neighbors good hey a
mess yeah this map neighbors the best
paper maker whatever you know what I
meant well not this me there's a keypad
in here no where'd you go Babu booby
where'd you go yeah me my right yummy Oh
over here just keep that in here okay no
whoa no please oh god I cried oh god
there's how many numbers okay no I'm
gonna read them to you no I got how are
we gonna do this we got to write them
down 400 then I'll destroy zero 192 why
would you try that one this only one
keypad oh sorry didn't we do nothing but
okay seven one six two seven one six two
I did it unlock the door
[Applause]
no not even a little bit I didn't waiter
already put in the numbers I didn't I
guess the number
you're so lucky I guess the right number
there okay no that was like 10 to 12
different numbers we got lucky
yeah I just grabbed one that I thought
might be random Oh
I even noticed seen them was coming down
to the last second okay oh hello now I'm
on my toes things have gotten a little
dicey around here you need a [ __ ] mark I
have a book it thank you I've already
gone like 10 jumps years ago so I'm
clear I'm good let's get out here let's
confess our sins to this mysterious
stranger you can confess your sin I did
not but if you face your fears so that's
kind of good all right Bo this door is
open a bowl wow we won the last puzzle
and we won is there any ending sequence
I think that's it well to be honest I
don't know if this counts as us escaping
cuz there's nothing pops up on the
screen yeah wait a minute yeah oh this
door I think I have just the key I'm
just gonna close my eyes for a second
okay I see you don't see me die kill us
he's frickin mean so mean there's more
Lucas penumbra gosh good lordy Lou sorry
Laurel Lou oh lord save holy sweet thang
oh my got a key
Lucas a nursery key that we found so
anyway we
wandering around for about five minutes
trying to solve puzzles after we solved
them yamimash is just being silly
applause so anyway this has been death
of the dream for you can check out every
other part some of them are on my
channel summer them all and you on
Yami's channel they're all in the
description also check out Yami masters
channel right now ish or in the next day
or so for the other horror map that we
did right yummy we're gonna do that
right now yeah yeah I'll have that one
very soon
click on his face thanks again Yami for
joining me no problem and thank you
everybody for watching and as always we
will see you in the next video
[Music]